بصلة بصلة بصلة *** بصلة أنا أنا بصلة
أنا بصلة أنا أنا  *** أحمي أحمي الإنسان
أعطي مناعة أنا أنا *** مناعة للأبدان
أنفع القلب أقويه *** ولرأسي عدة ألوان
أنا أنا أنا بصلة
أنا بصلة والبصل هام *** عنى لن يكفى الكلام
أحمي من نزلات البرد ***  وأعالج بعض الزكام
بصلة بصلة
أنا البصلة يا حلوين *** ومعادن في وفيتامين
أعطي للأطعمة مذاق *** ولجسمك أعطي بروتين
أنا بصلة أنا أنا بصلة *** أحمي أحمي الإنسان
أعطي مناعة أنا أنا *** مناعة للأبدان
أنفع القلب أقويه *** ولرأسي عدة ألوان
أنا أنا أنا بصلة
بصلة بصلة بصلة *** بصلة أنا أنا بصلة
إني طبعا يا صغار ***  أغنى أنواع الخضار
ألياف في وحديد ***  كي تنمو مثل الكبار
بصلة بصلة
لا يستغني عنى الناس ***  للصحة والأكل أساس
فأنا غني بمعادن ***  صوديوم بوتاسيوم ونحاس
أنا بصلة أنا أنا بصلة *** أحمي أحمي الإنسان
أعطي مناعة أنا أنا *** مناعة للأبدان
أنفع القلب أقويه *** ولرأسي عدة ألوان
أنا أنا أنا بصلة